this is a production of Cornell
University
welcome everyone I'm picking up a little
flash flash hopefully they'll be in
sight that goes with it oh it's this
light okay
I wanted to share with you some of the
work that we've been doing here at
Cornell focusing on reducing tillage
it's it's a collaboration that goes
across several universities in sort of
regions as we have a partner in Michigan
where you have some faculty there Dan
Brainard and Sophia xandrie who are on
our project and so some of the process
some of the experiments that we're doing
here in New York are repeated there as
well as mark Hutton who's here another
collaborator up in Maine and along with
Eric gallant and so this work out what I
want to share with you is focused in on
trying to integrate cover crops into
strip tilled systems and so a reduced
tillage system in organic vegetables but
we've been working with organic
vegetables in trying to adapt reduced
tillage systems to them for many years
and started our work primarily in
conventional conventionally managed
vegetables and a lot of that was funded
with sare but now we're trying to sort
of see how can we adapt and integrate
these systems for organic vegetables and
without the tools that our conventional
growers have with herbicides one of our
most important concerns and
considerations is how do we design these
with cover crops so we can actually be
managing weeds well in the system so
when I talk about reducing tillage we're
focusing on and we use reduced tillage
we're not doing a straight no-till here
we're looking at trying to decrease the
intensity the frequency and depth of
tillage or soil disturbance over time so
there are some systems that people work
on that are looking at rotational
tillage where you're playing rotate
tillage at certain parts of your
rotation and in our case we're primarily
are focusing on strip tillage we use a
number firth type a deep zone tiller and
this is a tool that creates an arrow and
a restricted area of soil disturbance
you have on this if you've not seen one
of these before the implement itself has
a cutting culture to cut through residue
and then a shank that you said to
operate below a compacted layer of soil
and so the goal is to fracture the
compacted layer compacted soil and then
you have a cup of
this here of that actually help break up
and create a nice little mound of soil
that would be right in the area where
you're planting so you're trying to
create all of your tillage and soil
disturbance in a narrow band of soil
that is prepared for planting direct
seeding or transplanting and so we opted
for this in our area which is more of
the northern tier because we wanted to
make sure with vegetables that we
couldn't protect the early season
establishment
so having soils warm quickly and having
the crop get to a good start so we're
not seeing a delay in the actual crop a
lot of vegetable crops aren't always as
vigorous and Hardy is some of the field
crops and so trying to optimize those
conditions early on so and the other
thing about the strip tillage is it
because it is it's sort of compromised
where it's not a straight no-till we do
have some different advantages to the
system we're restricting the tillage to
that in row area and so soils are
warming they're more quickly we can get
increased mineralization rates because
we do have disturbance there and so
we're adding air oxygen and disturbing
the soil there's a better seed bed for
like I said for seeding into in some
cases we can incorporate fertilizers if
they're actually in that area and in
some of our work with conventional
growers we're able to actually apply
fertilizer behind the shank deep into
the soil so it's available to the crop
and you're dealing with compaction in
that area it also allows us to sort of
keep this undisturbed area between there
where if we have a cover crop we can
retain a multi on the surface of the
soil which can help us actually conserve
some soil moisture and ideally protect
from erosion protect from water movement
across the field very quickly as well as
creating this habitat for beneficial
Zoar pests
we've seen some evoke and generally
contributing to soil health so that's
some of the advantages but it does have
its disadvantages as well because
certainly when we're trying to manage
that residue and we're restricting the
width of our tillage we can still deal
with problems with residue getting
accumulating in that area making it
difficult
create the kind of seedbed we want and
so this is one of our big challenge with
cover crop integration into a strip till
is cover crops can still end up either
being pinned or the root balls of
themselves will create interference
despite that and the activity of that
tool and so as a result you can have
some problems with stand four seeds fell
contact if you still don't have an
optimized soil condition for getting a
good germination of some of our more
dense more a tender across and then cope
it so if they can be maybe 12 inches
wide that's tricky to cultivate in and
so we've been always we've been trying
different tools but how you actually
cultivator managed using equipment based
approaches in that narrow zone and then
between the row dealing with the residue
particularly if we have a really wet
year and you have that mulch in place
you still have to cultivate through it
so what are the tools that you have in
hand in order to pull that off and then
in some cases because we're not actually
disturbing the soils there and in
organic system word that would also
contribute to not having as much
nitrogen that's actually being
mineralized for the whole system for the
roots the crop to have available to it
so there are some challenges with it and
those are the what we've been trying to
explore and especially with organic
system we want to be able to reduce
tillage as part of that sort of overall
soil health approach and in order to
really advance it we can do this on a
bare ground we can reduce zone building
with bare soil and yes we can create
conditions fairly easy but as soon as we
add cover crops we had complications but
we know that when you stack these
approaches we have a more improved
benefit to soil health so that's what
our goal is to sort of figure how do we
integrate these four organic
so some of the basics around managing
cover crops for reduced tillage that are
sort of true in managing cover crops in
general that we're trying to seed at the
appropriate time to have a good biomass
that's going to provide some of the
benefits of cover crops in and
traditionally a lot of seasoned people
who use don't ill say kill early kill
effectively to try to manage the residue
but in our case with organic we're
trying to figure out how we have to wait
for that killing step in order to
actually terminate the cover so how do
we how do we deal with that in our case
we have chosen to do our work with flail
mowing we're not rolling in these
systems and so that's a distinction I
wanted to make for sure is that in a
rolled system where you have much more
cover and you're creating that solid mat
that tool wouldn't works you're in a
no-till system and in our case in the
more upper part of the Northeast our
soils are cooled are much cooler under
that system and other experiments in the
past haven't worked as well you can do
it with later planted crops like
squashes and sometimes with larger
seeded crops like sweet corn but you
have to delay your plant to make it work
and so we chose to work with the strip
till system that it's a compromise
between full width tillage and then
no-till and so one of the challenges
again is sort of to be able to have that
soil prepared and and the conditions
correct for actually being able to plant
into it and then manage the crop
optimize that yield but we in our
experiments we set this up to look at in
in the past we've looked at both winter
keeled cover crops using like okie
combinations and the nice thing about
using those in a reduced sale system is
that they're out of the way there you
don't have to deal with them in the
following year there are the residues
don't interfere but trying to really
optimize these systems for the winter
hardy type covers lebra like a cereal
rye in a vet this is where we have to
think carefully about our planning and
our management so the way we said about
to look at alternate management systems
for cover crops in in this particular
trial where we're integrating cover
crops
strip till is think about the ways that
we're terminating the cover and so we
had three treatments that we use for
termination
we used the traditional sort of flail
and drop the mulch leave the cover crop
in place and so we're calling that a
mulch treatment because it's basically
setting on the surface of the soil it's
left in play another system is what we
call a cut and carry in which the covers
are flail top and then removed with a
wagon so their flail chopped into a
wagon and the residue is completely
removed from the field so the roots are
still intact but the serf the
above-ground biomass is gone so it
doesn't interfere then with practices
that happen later in the season and then
the third is sort of the control where
we would mow the cover crop but then
incorporate it with rototilling so then
the again the residues out of the way
but it's incorporated into the surface
of the soil so hopefully not interfering
with any of the other practice and we
looked at it with basically three kinds
of cover crop mixes in this case it was
we use the winter rye and hairy vetch we
also use a winter rye in a crimson
clover and then a straight hairy vetch
planting and so for each of those mixes
we use these different combinations of
termination strategy prior to then going
in and doing strip tillage so this is
the way that we're trying to see how we
can bring them together in these
experiments we also had a side dress
nitrogen application because in our
previous work in organic reduced Hill
nitrogen does appear limiting and so we
wanted to see how and if the
supplementary side res event would
actually address a limitation that
wasn't it all due to the tillage system
specifically
so um so those are that working with a
uniformly exceeded type of a mix where
you're mixing the Rye and the vets for
example and putting it across the field
as a mix whether it's drilled you have a
mix is one strategy but we also wanted
to look at what would happen if you
segregated your cover crops into strips
and so planting putting your legume
cover crop in the row where you intend
to plant and keep the cereal rye or the
the grain cover in between the rows you
maintain a residue there so trying to
optimize the spatial distribution of the
cover crop and also then facilitate
possibly the use of the strip tiller
in order to create the kind of zones
that we wanted for planting
so in this case it's generally here you
have this mix and when you have this
legume a legume and your cereal mixed
together your nitrogen is also
distributed from the legume across the
field but by creating and segregating it
where we're putting all of the legume a
right in the zone where we would strip
tail and plant the crop we try to
concentrate the nitrogen that's fixed by
that Liam into the area where the plant
the crop will be grown so we we just
felt that not only do we get the benefit
in this system of actually concentrating
the nitrogen many of those legumes are
easier to manage and the residue
wouldn't be as problematic in a strip
tilt system so there was two benefits
that can be explored with
so in order to look at the strip planted
we use the same cover crops we had
winter rye between the row and hairy
[ __ ] in the row a crimson clover in the
row or none
and so we maintained the serial the
winter rye in between and again in all
of these cases basically they were
planted in the fall and then flail mowed
and dropped in place and then strip the
zone builder was used in across the
field and in this case the zones were
built right over where the legume was
and so we sort of we created that sort
of plant racking and we seeded these
so again and there's a the mixes for all
of these mixes we had these three kinds
of termination but then in the case of
the strip planted we only we just failed
and then we stir it as own built and
then looked at how a cabbage crop would
perform so in all of these we use the
cabbage crop just an overview of a basic
timeline was drilling the cover crops in
September and then in the spring mowing
the cover crop and then a couple of
weeks later zone building and planting
so the cover crops had some time to
actually dry now before we did the zone
building and the planting so these are
just a few pictures of the mulch system
so this is the mix of the Rye and the
hairy vetch this is typical what you
typically see when you're actually
planting these in the field the rate on
the Rye was a sixty pounds per acre and
then the vetch was at a twenty pound per
acre rate
and then this is what it looked like for
strip planting with nothing this is just
the Ryba tween the rose and then nothing
planted in the row and so where we would
zone build
is right in this area here so the zone
once this has been playable zone builder
would be run right through this area and
then here's a neat picture where we have
the hairy vetch that's planted in the
area that we would be zone building and
then the crimson clover to give you an
idea of how it looked like prior to
terminus
and so first thing I wanted to share is
the overall biomass of the cover crops
just to give you a sense of how these
grew and this experiment in its design
was replicated also in Michigan with Dan
Brainard and so he was doing his
experiment on a sandy loam soil and this
is information from 2016 a dry year and
they were really challenged there
because of irrigation and the lack of
moisture and so you can see that their
biomass was much lower in their
experiment but when you look across what
we had at our trial that was in here in
the ethic area and free bill at our
organic research farm the cereal rye was
the bulk of the biomass and in fact
where we had just the veg crop a fairly
low biomass again this was just that
they had an oat nurse crop that went out
with it but it was just primarily betch
in the feet in the system and whether it
was stripped planted or if the [ __ ] and
the Rye were mixed and brought sort of
planted a uniformly across the field
about the same amount of biomass was
generated so there wasn't a big
difference in the amount of biomass
within a combination of cover crop
in the when we looked at the amount of
total nitrogen that was in the bio of
the above-ground biomass this is again
to give you a sense of the contribution
of the legume as well as the rai to the
subsequent crop because it did play out
in the performance of the crops
afterwards so having the straight [ __ ]
had the highest total amount of men in
the above-ground biomass so despite
having a fairly low total dry biomass
above-ground they still had more
nitrogen that was contributed to the
system
and that is an important point that will
be carried out later on with the results
in but in the strip planted as well as
the mixed crops we had about half as
much of the nitrogen that's contributed
by the legumes and also some that was in
the riot self but that just gives you a
sense of the total amount of nitrogen
that was in this above-ground biomass of
the cover crops that doesn't have say
anything about what was happening below
ground but just as an estimate of
above-ground
you
and so again once we flail mold
everything we went through means own
built one of the challenges in trying to
do zone building especially with
something like rye is the a heavy amount
of residue and so having the right doing
some work with make sure you bro
cleaners in front of your implements is
really important especially in front of
the planter and it was it could be
challenging this was a picture from
Michigan where they had it integrated
into their strip tool unit where they
could do the everything in one pass we
had to sometimes use a separate pass and
in the first year but having that that
row cleaner in front really was
important even though we might have
stripped planted it we still had to move
the residue out of the way
it's when you flail it still gets in the
way and it can still create not it can
impact how well that strip tiller works
but this is just a picture of how it
looks afterwards you have these bands
that are disturbed and ready for
planting after we've actually gone
through with the strip those o builder
and so depending on the mix of the cover
crop the residue lasted different
amounts of time over the season and so
we definitely in the case of the ryebeck
sort of at the beginning of the season
you can see a lot of that R is present
and it lasted quite a bit later this is
in a dry year so it did actually have
some residual effect and in the past we
found about three weeks is the best we
get as far as weed suppression from an
in from a cover that's in the row after
it's been mowed so that's about it but
even in the Bechet did actually have
some residual veg but not very much and
so this is important when it comes to
dealing weed management passes and so
this year brian a caldwell who's here he
does all of our equipment work which
were really grateful for he we have had
a hillside rolling cultivator at the
farm and we use it in this strip till
system and it did a really good job of
being able to deal with between row
weeds and so you can see here b2 in the
zone you can see where the zone is where
this cabbage is but then in between that
rolling cultivator actually move through
and and managed to actually do a really
nice job of cleaning up in between the
rows in spite of the remaining residue
that was there and that is um that is in
trying to put together the system it's
important you have to sort of think
through these pieces of it because it's
not just about adapting one part of the
system in order to make it work so
having the right road cleaners on
planters as well as on the zone tiller
having planned ahead for the weed
management strategy because dealing with
residue makes everything more
complicated
so this is just a picture of the
hillside that has these gangs of these
have this on them and you can adjust it
with hydraulics fairly small scale we do
everything on two rows I see all these
pictures from agronomic crops that are
much wider but we are we stay very
humble within our little to row system
so I just wanted to share here a little
bit about the nitrogen so I had shared I
told you earlier that you know in the
case of the veg a fairly high amount of
nitrogen was in the above-ground biomass
and when we rototilled that so these are
the three tillage systems the rototill
being the first bar then the cutting
carry where we actually flail chopped
and removed it and then verses the mulch
and was actually the traditional flail
drop it and then strip till it so that
residues on the surface that when in the
case of just post planting looking at
soil nitrogen levels that when we had
rode until the betcha
there was a real definitely a burst of
nitrogen that was mineralized and made
available to the crop right at planting
and that even carried through at the
time of side dress which is a few weeks
later so we still had the impact of that
practice in that management strategy
with the hairy vetch only in there and
the other crop cover comes fairly low
levels of soluble nitrogen measured in
the soils in the planting zone
but when and we looked at the cabbage
biomass in the response and the cabbage
sort of reflected that same amount of
nitrogen that was available where in the
case of the bench with the high-end
contribution we saw again a rototilled a
higher amount a larger plant higher
growth rate but that didn't actually
carry through all the way to harvest
when it came to harvest and then we came
to our yields they all caught up at the
end as far as with the hairy vetch so
this is two years of data from this
experiment 2016 and 2017 hot off the
press we here's the first year in the
second year and the first thing I would
just suggest is that the patterns are
really similar over both years what we
observed with these cover crop
combinations and these management
strategies so again the first bar would
represent the management rototill versus
the cut and carry and the mulch systems
where we just dropping it and leaving it
like a multi on the surface and this is
the and then our in this case we had the
the three different cover crops that we
compared the mix ryan hairy vetch makes
ryan comes in clover and a straight
bench
so when no nitrogen is applied basically
these were not side dressed so this is
the part of the experiment we didn't do
any side dressing the veg definitely
stood out as supporting the best yield
compared to the ride veg mix and the Rye
crimson clover so if you look at in the
case of just the bench at the management
system for that cover didn't matter we
had similar yields whether we wrote a
filled attend cover removed the
above-ground biomass or we left it on
the surface as mulch and so this is like
the really traditional strip till and so
it's in whether it was the veg the Ryan
crimson clover here again no significant
difference between a traditional
rototilled approach to dealing with that
cover or a strip tilt so this is good
news yes and
and it was same in both ears and if we
compare the cover crop combination for
rototilled basically the vetch was
performing better than the other the
combinations occurred the Rye crimson
clover was definitely poorer performing
in these systems and one of our
challenges with that is the NIC is sort
of an artifact of the experimental
design and that we had to employ remote
everything on the same day if we had
optimize the time of kill we probably
would have had better performance than
that and then when we looked at the
strip planted versus the mixed covers in
this case again here we have the bench
which is just a straight veg planet
across the field but it's included as a
nice comparison or a high nitrogen cover
and then and the other extreme we have a
rye with nothing no legume so you can
see here that the the light blue bars
are with no nitrogen applied it's a an
additional side dress and then with a
side dress nitrogen applied across all
of the cover crop mixes and so what
becomes really apparent is whether we
strip planted or a mix planted the cover
crops that the responses were sort of
were pretty much similar so the use of
that strip planted cover while it might
have provided some benefits to us as far
as being able to do the zone building
and actually implement the strategy
didn't result in much of a difference in
the yield compared to if we were just
mixing covers in a traditional way it's
kind of a bummer because we were really
thinking oh your hair on the track but
that's what we have learned here I'll I
think the other thing to note is that
we've always been concerned with organic
when we're restricting the width of
tillage through something like this that
we're not going to get all that nitrogen
mineralized through the disturbance of
soil that would be really important for
many of our vegetable crops and when we
did side dress we generally got a slight
improvement in we got an improvement in
the yield but it wasn't always
significantly different so for all of
these mixes in for veg adding that the
Supplemental side dress didn't really
improve the performance but for those
particular treatments where we were
really seeing a low nitrogen yes we did
see an improvement in the yields in
those cases so again this is year one
and year two very similar results in
Michigan where they had much drier
conditions a similar pattern they didn't
have the best treatment like we did but
again seeing the same if they in their
case because they had such poor growth
in their cover crops they didn't have a
lot of nitrogen fix it was very dry that
it's really where they had nitrogen
added that they were actually able to
support yields and get enough yields
from the cover and so the interaction of
nitrogen supplementation depending on
conditions becomes really important to
make these systems work
so just in summary for where we're at
with this work so again this is part of
a four-year project and this was two
years focused on strip till and cover
crops that our cabbage in a reduced till
system in the strip till did as well as
if we had read of tilled so we didn't
see we had similar yields in the strip
tilled and the rototilled sometimes with
a cotton carry system when we were
removing all that bug ground biomass we
did see a slight depression in the
performance of the cabbage in the yield
loss which is make some a sense if
that's actually contributing to the
nitrogen for the crop and then I didn't
show all of the combinations where we
added nitrogen but generally improved
the performance of the crop and I think
certainly in some years with more
rainfall where there could be other
stresses it's a logical thing to be
including a side rest application but we
didn't always see a yield benefit the
veg only cover crop really did optimize
the cabbage performance it which is
interesting because it's actually it
doesn't create as much residue that you
have to manage but we haven't looked at
other sort of benefits to soil health
and we didn't look at carbon or any of
the other indicators that might suggest
that you know to balance what are the
outcomes of using this cover crop
combination with reduced tilt and so the
strip tailed plan and covers helped but
they didn't actually it wasn't that much
different well we thought it would help
us really make the system work it wasn't
that big of an improvement and it
certainly didn't it facilitated the
reduced tillage but we didn't see a
difference in yield so that's kind of
where we're at with it and just wanting
to highlight again the partnerships and
the research that's going on here across
these different institutions
and I want to call out Ryan Marr who
works in the program and Brian Caldwell
as well they are really the energy that
makes this whole thing roll
so if we well we I think we we flailed
it and thisis so I think it would
probably rolled at the same time I think
that it's primarily the cold soils and
then the rolling restricts our ability
to do any kind of rescue with
cultivation later in the season so
that's one issue and those are the
primary ones to why we didn't roll and
we don't have a roller crimper that's
another one but I do have I have a
rolling stock chopper I mean I've tried
this in the past and worked with Steve
Groff back in in the 2000s where we
would actually roll covers using
different you know different ways of
chopping and rolling and crimping but in
an organic system where it's even more
I think restricted and the soil
temperature makes more it's more
important to me at this point
now yes I've done it one way I think in
using a drill of blocking holes and so
no I don't tell me how is it
the cabbage is a 30 inch spacing and our
grain drill has 7 1/2 inch rows so
there's 4 rows corresponding to each row
cabbage so yes our drill has a large so
we could just block 2 rows to to the
holes for the large seed and put the
large seed through going between the
rows and then in the small C we would
block we would take off just the other
[Laughter]
there's other there's other like a cedar
that I've used in the past that we could
actually depends on where the auger is
in it and so if the auger is below the
seed box then we were able to actually
block fully and we could mix the thief
but when we did when we were doing hairy
vetch in the strip and Brian a strip we
had to mix oats with it to slow down the
flow so we created that's how we created
a bat we were able to regulate the rate
so we could get the rate of fetch that
we wanted this by using those so it's a
you're getting a really good thing
instead yeah so in
this experiment we aren't we aren't in
the same field in both years but in the
past when I've done experiments looking
with zone building in the same field we
go 15 inches we offset each year so well
strip the well Zone till in one area the
first year then we'll move to the middle
the next year and then experience
growers over time who are able to keep
with the system are able to actually
bring the shanks up so they're not
disturbing it's deeply over time so
they're moving from the deep zone til to
more of a shallow strip till system so
that is that is a way in which the field
or soils will adapt over time to the
system
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu